[Música]
[Aplausos]
vamos conectar os pontos
imagina o que é sair de um país ou outro
imagina o que é sair de uma província
própria província
agora imagine o que é sair da casa dos
pais onde tem todo o conforto e vai pra
casa do tejo
em 1982 o meu pai fez o mesmo percurso
saiu do eixo para luanda procura de
condições melhores como muitos angolanos
na altura houve para luanda esperava ter
sido bem recebido mas não aconteceu
passou por várias dificuldades passou de
casa em casa e por vezes até chegou do
paraná rua mas ela não parou porque ele
tem um objetivo ao sair do iml saiu com
uma procura uma promessa de criar as
mínimas condições para poder chamar a
minha mãe se juntarem no cazenga dois
mais dois anos mais tarde isso aconteceu
à minha mãe mudou-se para a casan gaga e
aí começamos nosso lar i
eu lembro de várias histórias com que
nos pais contaram quando a gente crescia
de que muitos sacrifícios foram feitos
durante essa altura onde enquanto meu
pai procurava estudar e emprego ao lado
da minha mãe teve que abdicar de
variações
ela deixou de estudar e passar a vender
na praça e para poder ajudar em khost
que as necessidades
eu lembro que nossa casa sempre foi uma
casa que absorveria toda gente que vinha
das províncias na altura com os
conflitos armados a nossa casa tornou-se
o refúgio os familiares que vieram para
nossa casa a gente recebia com todo o
carinho e independentemente daquilo que
a gente porque aconteceu conosco no
passado depois de um certo tempo o meu
pai conseguiu arranjar um emprego que
permitirá com que ele viajasse durante
três a seis meses
durante todo o tempo a minha mãe ficava
gerir a casa toda vamos falar de 15 a 20
episódios numa casa de quatro cortes
hoje quando olho para trás vejo que
alguns princípios de gestão com que hoje
aplico aprende desde o meu berço
numa dessas viagens meu pai teve a
oportunidade de viajar por um período
mais têm se vivo ficou um ano a um ano e
meio fora e teve a oportunidade de levar
a família toda
daí nós saímos do cazenga nos estados
unidos foi um pulo tremendo
eu não estava acostumado não tava a a
família não estava preparado para essa
nova fase
eu lembro quando o bairro todo ficou a
saber que a gente ia para os estados
unidos
todo mundo ficou feliz porque era onde o
cazenga a dar um passo para frente
durante esse percurso
a única coisa que eu pensava era
realizar o meu primeiro sonho como
criança o meu objetivo era tocar na
parte de fora do avião
nós ao subir as escadas espera com
cafeína andasse teve uma pequena
oportunidade de que a mãe tocar para
fora do avião e realizei o meu primeiro
sonho esperado button mas durante esse
percurso muitas coisas quebraram muitas
barreiras andar pelo elevador pela
primeira vez aquela sensação no estômago
sentei e continuam a sentir até hoje
estávamos hospedados no hotel cinco
estrelas no 17º andar e alguém que saiu
do caso ainda para 17º andar em sto
eu literalmente ficava vidrado olhar
pela cidade e via os carros a circularem
a obedecer em cada paragem parecia uma
viagem futurística estava presente lá
observar tudo
depois de algumas semanas de matricular
na escola aí começou o terror e passamos
a ser as crianças que vinham da áfrica
mas só perguntar será que você já viu o
leão será que a áfrica tem uma televisão
mas todas essas barreiras quebraram
quando a hora do recreio tocou eu
conseguia ver pois as similares via uma
bola de basquete
vi uma bola de futebol e quando
convidado para jogar só que não entendia
fez tanta confusão porque eu dizia
futebol e diziam só ter mais postos no
campo todas as barreiras quebraram
porque passei do menino
que vinha da áfrica para o menino que
todo mundo queria que eu fizesse parte
da equipa
aí aprender com que o desporto podemos
quebrar algumas barreiras
depois de um certo tempo as coisas
começaram a se tornar normal já aprendeu
a falar inglês já tinha uma menina que
gostava e tentava conquistar mas depois
houve a quebra
tivemos que voltar pra luanda luanda
voltarmos no talatona
nós estamos a falar do talatona 20 anos
atrás sem avenidas em academia vai
literalmente é uma via com que ninguém
queria se meter a chance de se mudarem
para lá do promundo estavam a dar um
passo atrás
passamos um período de adaptação que
saindo do casal português não tava
professorado
vamos com estados neide esquece de falar
português voltar pra quê agora imagina o
bullying etapa passada durante o
percurso todo outras crianças chamavam
para dizer que não fala roth ou desviar
hoje rio mas mais uma vez procurava
sempre me reinventar para que as coisas
possam normal e lembrei de que o
desporto sempre foi uma baixa foi sempre
foi uma algo quebrou todas as barreiras
tentei basquetebol já não tava dá certa
futebol nada até foi introduzido o voto
é bom quando o meu professor sesa que
dizia sempre que através do esporte
podemos quebrar todas as barreiras
sociais e que dedicando e esforçando
conseguimos conseguimos chegar a um
nível mais alto mas depois de um certo
tempo havia uma certa febre das pessoas
irem para fora pudesse formar e eu
também queria fazer isso porque tinha
uma missão não terminada quando a
primeira vez que eu fui pro estados
unidos ainda era criança
mas o meu 18 anos queria fazer alguma
algo mais e isso aconteceu em 2009
viajei por estados unidos para completar
minha missão a missão era terminar o
curso de engenharia mecânica 12 moções
um dos sonhos do meu pai era ter um
filho formado em engenharia e eu fui com
essa missão de poder realizar o primeiro
ano foi extremamente simples porque já
venha a sair daqui com algumas bases o
segundo ano
foi simples mas o terceiro não comecei a
ver fumo
o encanto pela engenharia desapareceu
procurava fazer qualquer coisa para
parar ou para desistir até desde 86 mas
não deu certo
mas sempre que olhava para trás e via as
dificuldades que meus pais passaram e
mesmo assim meu pai conseguiu terminar a
faculdade não tinha nenhuma razão poder
desistir
então o objetivo era terminar a missão
mas enquanto isso estava preocupado
porque o meu tempo nos estados unidos
que meu curso estava acabado ainda não
ter encontrado o meu propósito até khan
no outro ano foi introduzido ao curso de
empreendedorismo social em são francisco
esse curso literalmente muda mudou a
minha vida diz pm das fórmulas de
termodinâmica passei a focar nas pessoas
eram sempre com o cachorro estava focado
em resolver problemas das pessoas
todo o egocentrismo estava deixado de
lado eo foco era simplesmente as pessoas
havia encontrado o meu propósito mas só
que esse propósito encontrei numa outra
cidade que trazer isso pra angola em
2015 voltei em luanda pra continuar a
dar sequência ao meu propósito que pelo
tj consegue encontro entender e coleira
meu propósito mas não foi tão fácil
assim que sair do centro com que tudo
era perfeito tem a solução ideal mas
tínhamos que readaptar isso a nossa
realidade
três mais três anos mais tarde
conseguimos realizar o nosso propósito e
eu creio que nesse momento estamos no
bolso de todos que estão aqui
eu conto essa história um pouquinho do
meu e do meu histórico a mostrar com o
que é possível é possível que alguém sai
do eixo e numa aldeia fazer algo
diferente é possível alguém que sai do
cazenga e sonhar e realizar
literalmente há dez anos atrás estava
terminar o ensino médio no colégio por
trás da avenida e eu estou aqui num
telex aproveitou também a ocasião de
agradecer a todas as pessoas que me
ajudam a conectar esses ponte aos pais
que passaram os princípios sólidos com
que ainda tem hoje os professores que me
incentivaram várias vezes a continuar
aos amigos e sócios patrice wilson
seneme que continuam a ajudar a conectar
os ponte aos irmãos que apesar das
minhas relações continuam sempre a
apoiar a deus por colocar todas as
opções na minha vida e alessandra por
ajudar a balançar a a minha vida pessoal
ea minha minha vida profissional
a mensagem a questão que eu coloco pra
vocês é o seguinte se você se conectar
em todos os pontos do vosso passado
todos o salto em baixo pode ser a voz
propósito obrigado
[Aplausos]